[Music]
[Applause]
now obviously there is some sort of
tissue connection from this point
so I threw the touch in tension able to
manipulate four centers position in
space
so I can't just aim it in the hallway
and I don't need a super grip to do it
you don't eat them and you can't even do
it with finger finger Thanks I must say
to do that they're doing that largely
I'm just saying philosophically as
possible physiologically as possible
okay so it's very much like the EDB
drill if you're going around for mass
you're pushing like that you're not
connecting so when you do this technique
and you go like that you see how I'm
going around and you are now dependent
upon this pulling you want to find per
sector in the last one I was here
pushing like this in this one I'm
pushing like this they're not doing this
would I go like this you see how she
rolled right off where her need was pay
attention to this meat market in space
you see when you project your Center in
the last class
did you notice begin that your feet move
before you fell same thing watch these
moving about that far okay
in the better that we can the less they
start absorbing in the shoulder you get
more okay so let's just try to give that
some direction you looks just like levy
need rope feel is dope sha sha position
move his mouth just like you can find
his Center from here
you're now finding it from here do you
see this this way so it's just your
you're finding it now not with your
fingertips that with the forearm wrist
area of your body got it okay let's
let's bring that in I'm not going to go
around this
I'm going to
I'm moving this not not a figurative
thing I have to Center
okay now the mechanical assumption is
that their energy is going to go from me
and into his Center which now on this
place is sector
I will displace him if there's any
leakage of that energy they'll be less
displacement of the center okay so you
can think of it as a fire hose there the
hose is very full of pressure and it's
all going in the direction I wanted to
go if you start poking holes in that
hose it doesn't come out very powerful
at the other end that's very much like
in this
energy is being absorbed because I can't
hold that angle it's made to weep so I
go to here and I go to push it and it's
letting energy go out because my elbow
outside of my shoulder I start fine here
and I go like this and energy can't go
up because it's so weak going down if
you look at these two pylons that's not
the you can wear spiral the inverse
spiral is doing that shape so this can't
be it so he his hand would not be in
that
even if I was strong enough this is not
the pattern that's going to get me and
tactically sound even if I can
manipulate enough this is not tactically
sound because he has a lot of position
balance based still what I want to do is
start picking him up see that no don't
start here and then go like this
oh this is no energy coming out of my
heart and if there's no energy coming
out of my arm it doesn't take as much
energy to displace it so my arm can be
relaxed and I'm not possibly okay so
those who have the power I'd like you to
start having faith take your over muscle
segmentation out of it the rest of you
are working on this pattern and the best
way for that is for honest to Kimmy so I
am pushing from my Center and I take
every opening he gives me I'm not
countering him I'm not well like this
okay I just keep the connection
are you actually weaker that's what it's
saying if you if you didn't have the
nice fish you're not me
they will inverse this thing meaning
book it's when you've wanted the power
that you didn't have the want made you
not have it and that's what you're
actually seeing it so you want her to go
flying like you went or like you saw and
you go like that you see that challenged
my arm you get it or you want to go far
like you suck you just hold the floor
but if you see my arm pay attention to
where is she with my arm falls right
she's over there
draw draw
you see there's time now for that this
is occupying her as much as me
attempting my go to draw it's going to
be in space she can fulfill okay try to
stick to the floor that bar is not
screwing with me because it's heavy and
solid okay so here it is not screwing
with you when they're heavy so they're
doing their job but don't let it fool
you because that's where you start those
powerless okay you want to be a solid
bar this is just conditioning exercise
I'm here do you feel me right so I when
I'm going to get I should be able to
displace her okay she has to reconcile
it whoa there it is okay that's the one
where she goes here you already got all
supposed to take it
it's percussive okay so very much like
if I hit you guys are throwing like
there's too much fixes come fixated you
are ballistic movement internally
internally the list
human expert at leaf is a movement okay
so this is all moving
I have not flexed yet and I will flex my
stomach just like - I'm going through
our first pot or someone's coming to hit
me in the stomach
yeah flexing - right it should feel like
that
[Music]
by your movement
so every Yong is the part you're lusting
after it's only made by the end so the
end is this this is not only you can see
that energy goes up there's less energy
young needles you bring the end into it
yeah and also more tradition so you guys
if I bleep when I do this so I stood
ishi
I am using the task of projecting her to
test whether my code is asleep so that's
that's what we were doing right out
projecting to do now
[Music]
and play
so as it boast to me pushing her to my
elbow will not be here in space but the
relationship to my torso will stay the
same
do you see so it won't go like this here
stays the same just wrist one this way
so when I come back and this energy
comes you're taking the initial
[Music]
[Applause]
okay do you understand that people are
trying to do the other way but they're
doing this instead but this movement
[Music]
right and I have taken conflict angle
maybe stronger than you destroy if you
can win the conflict hatred good work
well his face is coming in it's in that
o'clock isn't that your enemy of mine
but you don't feei to know people going
right those are promoted clubs and again
you only work if I can generate more
massive impact leading okay what we're
doing is something different so his head
he's going to stop sooner or later got
it
that's what I she did it so the Energy's
not coming this way when I make content
so that's why it looks like he runs into
my fists you see that it's not this here
is being
[Music]
you have to learn this do you understand
you have to learn how to push into your
physiological form so that you can we're
going to separate anger and fear from
presence if you tip if you're right you
always always have
you are just hiding that you still slave
the fear okay so we need you to pull a
minute but inside there's no hatred
there's no fear there's no anger it is
just pure this okay so that's not it how
do i how do I get you to come in more
it's wasting for answer you got them you
ask them I was not thinking that because
you're afraid girl holding out there you
want them to come in you're like the
Venus flytrap or something or the hunter
right so that takes courage so I let you
in I'm going to hit you with everything
okay these are all fear afraid she will
hold it up and there is no it's not soon
to be strength on strength speed against
speed and they have so lemon right she
has she was gonna do my fault does she
come back and try to figure it out or
she can come back and go hey baby slow
down but she can't get a free one like
that okay
you got to pay that's all
you're not
[Music]
okay understand that psychological
necessity of having presence separate
from anger and fear okay
this was this kind of roots in the
battlefield and battlefield arts are
team oriented because teams wins you
fight five individuals with three
coordinated people they're gonna win
with three coordinated people and that's
not a special thing you kind of realize
that just in the hue
evolutionary trait of not wanting to die
you start realizing hey we tend to
survive more things the more coordinated
our combative efforts are so you see it
in modern law enforcement it's all team
oriented you lose when you're not a team
that's also why one of the counter
strategies you should have is how to
disorganize the opposing team make them
individuals
well team organization requires
coordinated movements efforts ends and
that requires decision-making capacity
and you have no decision-making capacity
in fear or anger or raw aggression you
just can't do it
so Budo has a very practical reason for
why you don't want to have your
dichotomy be I'm I am aggressive and
present or I'm timid and yielding got it
presents and yielding have the same
emotional centeredness they're not peaks
and valleys
so yielding is not retreating
and going forward is not attacking you
know what I mean can you understand both
are aggressive both are attacking but
they're not I got a little reach for us
this is not it
if in the face of yin and Yan I am
either under or and I not employing a
concept of even-keel centeredness then I
have not reconciled in any on internally
and then the art is external to me I am
emotionally clashing with this thing in
either case just in one case I'm winning
and in the other case I'm losing we
don't we don't move beyond winning and
losing
you're just present
your pulse is you could use it as a
metric should not be different if you're
doing Eevee me or you're doing 10
o'clock it should be the same pulse and
the feeling should be the same Luke is
never going to never be able to say I
really like your 10 conversion because
it's so much softer
if you get it
so if that's our goal then we must train
it in a way whether it is exposed when
we're not doing that and that's like
things like let them in knock them down
when you take your noggin Wazza
to that level then you guess who Kenny
has to rise to that same level of
reconciliation because what are we going
to want to do is you can start a start
not coming in or we do the opposite it's
just some personalities like I keep
pulling out so I'm just go for it but
it's not present in either case
so when Naga works on their presence
then Kim must work on their cousins and
you can do it the other way around too
if you're kami is sincere enough in this
mission that Naga will not be able to do
the technique because everything that
a leaky hose the whole of the hose is
going to be exposed
[Music]
so let's keep that in mind and the way
that we deal with this because training
can get rough is if you are senpai you
try not to kill them so you will throw
them to the level of their ability if
you see them crash lower to gear okay if
your co high try to knock the hell out
of them that's your job take advantage
of it try to hit him wrong Panem as far
as you can to reveal budget this is
anger fear and this or whether you can
be present and still be Marsh the effect
if at any point is not working it's
getting too dangerous
you're getting triggered but one stop
getting triggered obviously you're
training incorrectly but we tend to tell
the other person slow down and then they
will slow down
you have another fallback I will watch
it and go hey just like today
he's trigger on you you're triggering
him no and what I will make the training
safe okay does everyone understand this
but really don't don't pretend that
you're on the mat and you're taking care
of there because you're not you're just
not pressuring yourself let the dojo
system and all of its fall backs and
allowances take care of and take care
keep the training or at least display as
best you can
any other questions comments